me
初めまして次郎と申します
僕は15年にわたって特殊メイク特殊造形の会社
自由路の代表を務めてまいりました
我々は
日本において
特殊メイクの命題ともやる
人体のリアルな表現の追記を行ってきました
それはすなわち
人体における様々な知識の習得と
イメージを具現化するための
技術の経営権際には他なりません
こちらをご覧ください
これはその追求の成果です
ケア等の一つ一つ
毛の1本1本
女の毛細血管から交際まで
すべて手作業で作られたものです
リアルでしょ
こういった
特殊メイクの技術は主に
映像の中で疲れてきました
ですが
僕はこの
実際に見ても
本物にしか見えないこのクオリティを
映像の中にとどめておくのはもったいないそう思ったんです
僕があるとき
日本のお祭りに行きそこで売られているお面を見て
この面が全てリアルだったらどんなに面白いかと
そう想像しこういったものを作りました
早い
これはリアルマスクです
この
liam へリアルマスクをかぶることで
誰でも簡単に
まったく別の人になることがあります
このやリターン
くれません
僕はこのリアルマスクの政策により
想像
想像したことで新しい可能性を生むといったことに気付くことができたんです
ご紹介が遅れてましたら
こちらの方こちらの方ですねは日本有数のバルーン会社
エアーテック代表の大曽根社長です
いつもお世話になっています
この大須の大曽根社長と一緒に作り上げたのが
へ
こちらになります
巨大リアルバルーンフィギュアです
松井秀喜さんを9メートルの高さで製作しました
これは
体があるんで顔はバルーンのベースに
巨大がリアルマスクを取り付けたものです
次に
これは
6m の現代アーティスト村上隆さんです
座りで6メートルもあるので
顔のマスクサイズで約2メートル
眼球サイズはおよそ25センチほどあります
これまで
バルーンではそのバルーンの均等に膨らんでしまうという特山より
リアルな顔の形の表現っていうのは難しいとされていました
ですがこの巨大なリアルマスクが
その問題を解決したんです
さらに
こういった経験に基づく確かな技術は
最先端の素晴らしいテクノロジーと結びつくことによって
リアル android へと
発展を遂げています
こちらです
オトナロイドと
コドモロイドです
そしてこちら
松コロイドです
そして
村上羅漢ロボです
アーチャー car
od ソはから
はい
ご覧のように
技術と知識に
イマジネーションをプラスすることで
時にはジャンルを超えて新しい技術を生み出します
そしてその新しい技術がまたさらに
テクノロジーと融合し発展
またイマジネーション想像することでより進化するのです
先ほどの android も
また
発展や進化を繰り返し
より人間的にもっと身近になる日がそう遠くない気がします
僕にとって知識や
技術といったものは絶対に必要不可欠なものです
ですが新しい可能性を生むにはイマジネーション
想像することが一番重要だと僕は思います
さて
ここで
イマジネーションにより
作られた
いくつかアイテムを紹介したいと思います
リアルがチーズバンドエイドです
通常のバンドエイドは
傷を覆い隠してしまいます
ですが
この傷バンドエイドは
ご覧のように
表面にいたそうな傷がついているので
必ず
皆さんに
心配してもらうことができます
そして次です
これは
リアルの耳が付いた
iphone ケースです
この iphone ケースを使えば
例えば
授業中であってもいいと c 彼女と電話することができます
もしもし
絶対にバレることはありません
そして
これがリアル変身メガネです
どんなにつまらない男でも
このメガネをかけることで
周りにいるみんなを笑わせることができます
ほら笑ったでしょ
こういった作品こういったアイテムたちにもこれから
発展や進化
発展や進化をもたらす可能性が眠っているかもしれません
最後に
僕の僕個人のアートワークをご紹介したいと思います
今から紹介する作品は
僕の活動の根幹である
イマジネーションを
具現化すること
それを
もっとも
原点である
僕の原点である筆の実を使って表現した作品になります
ご覧ください
ひとりの女性の生涯を負0-3で
face paint で
描いて表現しています
同じモデルに
ペイントするだけで老化させています
特殊な技術は一切使ってません
この女性の生涯は終わったかに見えましたか
さらに
小束して
花が咲きます
次この作品ですが
これは
after い名手つまり残像をテーマにしたフェイスペイントです
デジタル技術は一切使っておりません
そしてこれはドローイングヒューマン
一見平面に描かれたドローイング
会に見えますが
ご覧のようにこれも
モデルにフェイスペイントを行ったトリックアートです
そしてゾンビ
腕を噛みちぎるろうとしてるゾンビですが
見てわかるように
はいっ
噛んでいるその口は実は腕に描かれたものだったんです
こういった作品制作は
まだ小さな活動に過ぎません
ですが
創造し続けることによって
広がっていくその先を僕は見たいと思っています
アインシュタインはこう言っています
イマジネーション as つ
もわぁ important ターン
なお愛知
イマジネーション
塩サブぞわーっ
僕はこれからもイマジネーションの
大切さをかみしめて今後も活動していきたいと思っていますご静聴ありがとうござい
ました
me